Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and my Game of
Thrones countdown continues, I think we’re
on our third or fourth video.
During my Breakdown of the last trailer I
asked you all to submit questions and I picked
10 to answer with one bonus question.
Everybody really just wants to talk about
the Titan of Braavos, but I grabbed some other
good ones.
If you’re finding me for the first time
I’m doing a special countdown series for
the Season 4 premiere.
I’ve got a bunch of cool stuff planned so
subscribe to get everything.
I’m even doing a weekly giveaway once the
season starts.
Now it’s time to talk some Braavos.
Careful for spoilers if you’re not caught
up on the show.
Here we go.
Question Number 1 - Neto del Toro asks Do
you think we’ll see Cat of The Canals House
of Black and White this season based on The
Titan being in the trailer?
Based on that Titan, yes we will see Braavos
but not quite the way you think.
There’s a lot of different stories tied
up in that location during various parts of
the story, but the one I think we’ll see
is Ser Davos at the Iron Bank.
Remember Mark Gatiss is playing Tycho Nestoris,
someone who works at the Iron Bank.
Stannis had no money during season 2 when
he borrowed all those ships from Salladhor
Saan’s ships.
The funny thing about that scene was that
all that Saan seemed to want was to get to
have sex with Cersei when they took King’s
Landing.
But since that very expensive fleet was torched
with wildfire, Stannis has no more ships and
no money.
So Davos will get sent to borrow more.
Enter Mark Gatiss.
Question 2 - Fenrirnorgesen asks when the
show catches up to the books will the do a
prequel series like for dunk and egg or Robert’s
Rebellion?
Yes there will be a prequel tv series at some
point, but it will be set way way back in
the past.
So no Dunk and Egg and no Robert’s Rebellion.
George RR Martin was signed to an HBO development
deal of his own around season 1.
I personally want to see a series set in Old
Valyria before the doom.
It’s the same situation with Robert Kirkman
at AMC.
They also signed him to a development deal
for a Walking Dead spinoff show.
It’s just because those world’s are so
popular, and HBO and AMC want to keep that
type of content going for as long as possible.
No announcements have been made about the
Game of Thrones Prequel series, but it took
David Benioff and DB Weiss 3 years to make
the first pilot for the current Game of Thrones
show.
Plus Martin still has to finish Winds of Winter
and then write Dream of Spring.
He’s a busy man.
Question 3 - Taylor Simpson asks will they
add scenes for characters that aren’t in
Feast For Crows or Dance With Dragons?
You’re talking about the same thing they
did with Theon last season.
Yes, they’ll re-arrange things so that they
happen chronologically.
It just makes it easier to follow a story
when you don’t jump back and forth in time
too much.
JRR Tolkein had the same problem with his
books, so Peter Jackson had to re-arrange
the chapters for the movies so that events
unfolded one right after the other.
As far as extra things, they’re really just
blending Feast for Crows with Dance with Dragons.
They won’t cover all of those books, but
most of the characters that aren’t in Feast
are in Dance, so logically it made sense to
do events from the beginning of both books.
A lot of the later chapters will probably
spill over into season 5 though.
Question 4 - Vermalgab Boom asks Is anyone
going to go to Braavos since we saw the Titan?
Yes, Davos like I mentioned, but I also think
that we’ll see teasers at the end for other
characters that are going there.
There’s at least two or four I guess, depending
on how you look at it.
Question 5 - Sergio Vale da Serra asks, Do
you think Ned Stark will come back?
What do you think the cliffhanger will be
this season?
The only way Ned Stark could come back would
be as a Wight, and even then he’s lost his
head, so I don’t think the white walkers
would be able to re-animate his corpse.
The only way to kill them is to burn the bodies,
so I guess they could reanimate his head so
that he’s just a biter like the ones in
the Governor’s fish tank on walking dead.
As far as cliffhangers, there are several
events in the middle of books four and five
that would be good.
All of the characters have multiple oh shit
moments, so it will be amazing no matter where
they end things.
Question 6 - Steven U asks Will we finally
get to see Barristan Selmy fight this season?
I hope so, the show stays really close to
the spirit of the books and major plot points.
But it does take small liberties with characters.
As we’ve seen in the trailers, Daenerys
still has a major battle ahead of her and
while all the Barristan Selmy scenes make
him seem like more of a talker and less of
a stabber, I think he will get tough with
people.
Daario is really the stabby one in her camp,
the one who gets sent out to quote unquote,
take care of things.
Selmy is really more of a counselor, like
Ser Friendzone.
With way less creepiness about him.
Question 7 - Conner Peckham (no avatar) asks
I kinda want to start on the books, but I
want to start reading where the show is right
now.
Which book should I start with?
Honestly, you need to read the second half
of Storm of Swords if you really want to pick
up where Season 3 left off.
But if you want to be quick about it, you
can just read spoilers for that stuff and
start reading A Feast For Crows.
Season 4 is going to be weird in that it combines
chapters from the first half of both Book
4 and 5.
So you’ll miss out on some stuff no matter
what.
But I think if you’re going to read the
books, you should read them in the order they
were published, not in the order the show
is doing them.
When the season does start and I do videos
for the episodes.
I’ll try to reference chapters of events
when they happen on the show.
In case anyone wants to compare.
Question 8 - Lisa Cunningham asks How far
into the storyline of Cercei do you think
they will get this season?
I think we’ll only get about halfway through
her character’s arc.
So there will still be a lot of big stuff
spilling over into Season 5.
With all the mega stuff going on in King’s
Landing already, including everything from
her chapters seems like it would be too much
for the story to handle.
The problem with the show is that if it tried
to do everything in a single book for a season
it would be way too disorganized.
And remember, she’s not going to be in every
single episode.
Question 9 - Ryuga Zero asks Who do you think
is the most important character or will become
the most important character?
So this is a huge debate, but George RR Martin
has always said that he identifies with Tyrion
the most.
I always felt that a lot of fantasy authors
make some of the narrative autobiographical,
in the sense that the character they identify
with the most becomes the most important character.
That’s not always the case, but there’s
something really logical about the way David
Benioff and DB Weiss went about casting Peter
Dinklage.
He’s the highest paid actor on the show.
Yes, they are following the plot of the books
for the big stuff.
The other clear choice is Daenerys, she’s
been the face of the show on the posters and
everything for a couple seasons now.
The thing I really like about Game of Thrones
is that unlike say, The Hobbit or Lord of
The Rings.
There is no one single main character.
But if I had to pick it would be a tie between
Tyrion and Daenerys.
Question 10 - Henri-Martin Fayad asks How
do you think the first episode will start?
Typically the first episode of each new season
of Game of Thrones has started immediately
after the events of the previous season’s
finale.
So if you re-watch the last episode of season
3, we’ll start season 4 a few days after
that.
So Jon Snow just came back to the Night’s
Watch, Daenerys just freed all those slaves
and Jaime and Brienne just came back to King’s
Landing.
So those will be the places we’ll start
with in episode 1.
and one last Bonus Question - Ayan Tandon
asks how many seasons will there be?
The showrunners just did an interview with
Vanity Fair where they said they went to George
RR Martin’s house in New Mexico to learn
how the rest of the story ends for each character.
That’s just because by the time we get through
season 5, they’ll have passed the books.
They didn’t reveal any spoilers of course,
but they did say they have enough content
for 7 seasons and maybe an 8th, depending
if HBO would pay for it.
Believe me, they will pay for an 8th season.
For now, we can say confirmed 7, but in reality
I do think it will be 8.
So thanks so much for submitting questions,
this was a lot of fun.
I’m working on getting livestreaming running
on my channel.
So I might do live Q&A videos in the future.
I’m also working on doing live videos right
after shows end, like Talking Dead.
That probably won’t happen at least until
Game of Thrones starts.
I have a lot of technical details to work
out.
Be sure to subscribe to get the rest of my
countdown videos.
My next video is going to be a history of
Dragons in the world of Essos.
Remember they started out in Valyria, then
came to Westeros and so on.
That will probably post late late tonight.
Right now click here to watch all my breakdown
videos and click here for my Walking Dead
predictions, because we only have 3 more episodes
this season.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!